the Giants would have been smart to just
wave the white flag last night even
though the game was closed what didn't
we know we knew what the end result was
going to be the question is how do we
get there and for a while they made us
think the Giants did that they actually
could compete with the Dallas Cowboys
but eventually the clearly better team
emerges it was a blowout week one in
Dallas when the Cowboys beat the Giants
and now they get together again to cap
week 937 218 win by the Cowboys six
straight over the Giants there was a
time where the Giants just to get the
Cowboys fits it's been at least three
years ago
the Cowboys moved to five and three they
have a half game lead over the Eagles
and the Cowboys are four and O in the
division including the head-to-head
victory against the Philadelphia Eagles
so the Cowboys firmly in charge and they
did sputter early on but I got to give
him credit for not for not falling apart
right there coming off of their bye week
a little bit rusty they have the early
tone over on the throw by dak Prescott
that was picked up by and picked off by
Antoine Bethea
but and you know it just felt like it
took some time for it to get going but
but they didn't panic they didn't give
up they just pushed through it Peter and
the next thing you know it's it's a
blowout Mike what really occurred to me
watching this game is how helpless the
New York Giants are on offense and what
a helpless feeling it has to be for that
organization after spending the most
money in NFL history for a left tackle
in Nate solder drafting a guard will
Hernandez in the in the second round and
then trading your best pass rusher
Olivier Vernon for a very good guard and
Kevin Ziegler so basically you have
spent major resources on 60% of your
offensive line and that's what they've
got to show for it the line is awful
it's just awful and and and so at one
point in the game I think Joe tessitura
on ESPN said something like well they're
you know say Quan Barclay
I forget what what words he used but it
was something like well you know say
Quan barclays got to get with it
well every time say Quan Barclay touched
the ball he ran into a wall and you know
the Giants were helpless at the goal
line
it just it's got to be an incredibly
disheartening field because the players
who Dave gentlemen has put a lot of
stock in to come in and rebuild a huge
need position group are bad right now
anyway last night are playing poorly
yeah I agree with you completely in
Sigma Berkeley had 28 rushing yards that
was the lowest total of his career for
any game that he didn't exit early due
to injury if you're watching on NBCSN
there's one that popped but those were
few and far between for say Quan Barclay
last night the the offer and and you
know what when the offensive line is
terrible yes we do notice that the
offensive line is playing poorly but so
much more the blame goes to the
quarterback like what's wrong with the
quarterback what's wrong with the
running back well what's wrong with them
is they don't have time to do anything
then of an opening when the offensive
line plays well we ignore them and we
give all the praise to the quarterback
the running back the receivers in the
tight end but when the when the
offensive line just can't block and you
can't do anything and you know Peter I
saw it coming after that interception to
start the game when the Giants can't
punch it in for a touchdown you know
it's gonna be a long night that's that's
how you jump on a team early that's how
you set the tone early that was a huge
win for the Cowboys to hold the Giants
to a field goal because like okay that's
a little hiccup we're still the Cowboys
they're still the Giants now let's go
prove it even though it still did take a
while for that to go to 12 to 3 at one
point in the second quarter but there
was just always this feeling it was
inevitable that the Cowboys were going
to do what they needed to do Ezekiel
alley.the 139 yards rushing a
season-high for him
dak Prescott another good night shaking
off that interception playing well
enough to remind everyone that number
one he doesn't have a contract and
number two with each passing week it's
going to cost the Cowboys more to get
him signed so here they are you know it
was a rough start to the season they had
the three-game losing streak but that
they seem like they're the team that we
expected them to be from week one
yeah I mean you know if I'd feel better
about the Cowboys if they weren't so
sloppy and they just that was not a
clean performance by the Dallas Cowboys
last night and and again everybody every
team has some has some hiccups in the
course of a game but in my opinion the
Cowboys got three touchdowns you know
two touchdowns because the Giants
totally fell asleep in the secondary and
one touchdown because of Giants
sloppiness I look I I have no idea what
you say about the Dallas Cowboys after
that game last night they want a game
they should one or they should win and
dak Prescott played well but he had his
moments also so I think for the Cowboys
it's one of those survive in advanced
kind of games Mike yeah when you come
out of that game with a 37 to 18 final
score even though it was closer than
that if it's possible but it was closer
than that and it wasn't doubt for a
while you take that one and you say hey
we got the win now let's get ready for
Minnesota on Sunday Night Football and
the cat the black cat that we talked
about on the little two-minute TV only
stuff at the top of the show the black
cat actually was good luck for the
Cowboys because before the cat the
Giants were winning 9 to 3 dak Prescott
had 84 passing yards and an interception
after the cat Dallas outscored New York
44 to 9 173 yards three touchdowns no
picks for dak Prescott so the cat the
cat was a Cowboys fan the cat put the
kibosh on the Giants and by the way
there was an update from MetLife Stadium
for those wondering about the status of
our furry friend at tonight's game the
black cat ran off the field and
disappeared under a seating section once
we locate and safely capture the cat we
will take it to a veteran for
examination they ain't gonna catch the
cat I think the cat likes living in
MetLife Stadium if you think the cat
looks well-fed Peter the cats finding
leftover nachos and hot dogs and
hamburgers and whatever else is lying
around that cat isn't leaving Mike you
know here's what it's like and what it
must be like to be a New York Giants
right now you get in your car at the end
of that game you go for the ride home
you're a little dispirited because
you've just been embarrassed again and
you do have the cat I mean the biggest
bright spot on the evening for you is
hey honey did you see that cat how about
that cat that was unbelievable and so
that to me is the sad part right now for
the New York Football Giants and I did
like this work by the way yeah we got
the next-gen stats for the cat fourteen
point three miles per hour top speed and
untouched all night long because nobody
wanted to get close to that cat because
god knows what kind of diseases that cat
is carrying or with the cab with do do
you remember the old clip I think I
think it was a baseball game cat guy
picked it up and the cat like bit the
guy so you just don't want to make guys
yeah yeah you never know what a cat's
deeper yeah let's flip this to the
Giants and about where the Giants are
right now is a franchise at two and
seven they have the Jets this week
they've got some some tough games coming
up later in the season two points I want
to raise me let me start with Pat
Shermer year two you've mentioned this
before as it relates to Ben McAdoo in
hindsight Ben McAdoo did pretty well
with the Giants better record than Pat
Shermer through a season and a half when
you compare the two guys his Pat Shermer
in any kind of trouble or should he be
in any kind of trouble even though it's
only the second year of his time as head
coach of the team Mike I think he'll
probably be back for year three because
I think Dave gentlemen John Mara Steve
Tisch they understand that he is he came
in to a really bad situation but I think
somehow someway you know that what they
have to do what's really incumbent on
them right now they're never gonna be
anything offensively until they finish
the construction of the line and that
may or may not include Nate's older
because you know he just does not had a
good year
and and then I think after that I think
the most important thing
look they scotch tape a good pass rush -
a decent pass pass rush together at
times this year with a guy they got off
the street basically in Marcus Gould and
formerly the Cardinals but they have got
to address that in in my opinion you
know you're really paying the price and
look I'm not saying that Daniel Jones
isn't a good quarterback for the long
haul but right now you're paying the
price with basically not picking Josh
Allen in the draft by prioritizing
Daniel Jones at six over the pass rusher
and now you look and see how well Josh
Allen is playing in Jacksonville
he and Bosa are probably neck-and-neck
for Defensive Rookie of the Year those
are the two things but Mike there's one
other point I would make about the
Giants long term and that is I went to
the Ravens game on Sunday night Ravens
Patriots and I looked down and I saw how
how reenergized this franchise is with
Lamar Jackson and how Eric DeCosta and
John Harbaugh and the people who run the
Baltimore Ravens basically have made
this franchise a continuum excuse me and
they basically have not gone into any
sort of rebuilding phase at all and the
reason is because they were unemotional
about their quarterback and they said
Joe Flacco's had a couple of bad years
in a row we got to look to move on and I
think the Giants being so faithful for
so long while they weren't winning with
Eli Manning is really hurting them right
now because they didn't get started on a
rebuild until it was too late and that
leaves my next question Peter because
with the Giants having a game this
weekend against the Jets then there by
then at the Bears home game December 1
against the Packers and then a trip to
Philadelphia week 14 the last three
games dolphins at home at Washington and
the Eagles to wrap up the season at
what point do we begin to start hearing
from the media from the fans maybe from
within the organization that to properly
send to Eli Manning off into the sunset
we need to put him back on the field for
one or two or three games especially
since two of those last three games are
home games that you like people to show
up for and maybe they'll show up for the
Eli Manning farewell since the team is
otherwise giving them no reason to show
up I mean I don't know what good that
would do other than for the 900th time
to let the fans and and the Giants
alumni say how much they love Eli
Manning we know that I mean this is a
free I mean Mike if that happens I'll
just shrug my shoulders and you know if
it's not the best thing for the New York
Giants in 2020 then I wouldn't do it and
look it may be that Daniel Jones you
know has something wrong with them and
could use a week off and and and
whatever and that's fine but otherwise
if you hear if if that happens I just I
just think it's another example of how
the Giants prioritize emotion over
football well that's what's gotten them
in this problem you're absolutely right
the the Giants waited too long to pull
the band-aid off and now they have and
they see this they see what's under that
band-aid it's got a long way to go
before you get to where they need to be
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports